good morning Hank it's Tuesday landed in
London early in the morning not even
sure what day it was these buses by the
way are not just the cliche they're also
actual public transport got something to
drink it eat because I'm a rebel and
then came outside six minutes later and
the Sun was shining because England went
to the BBC to do a radio interview where
they let me play Elton John's actual
piano bottom that a piano dropped off my
bags at very nice hotel room featuring a
well-dressed headless woman and pages
from a children's book and there was a
gift bag from Penguin containing warm
English beer and Marmite naturally as
well as a sign to Steven Gerrard Jersey
which not to brag I look great in then I
broke one of my rules of conquering
jetlag but only briefly no laying down
took a taxi did the penguin offices
where there is currently a very schmancy
display for The Fault in Our Stars and
then went up to the tenth floor to
enjoyed the same view of London that
Winston Churchill once had during the
Second World War then I went to the
Guardian which has extremely nice chairs
and also a view of houseboats and canals
that reminded me of Amsterdam it was way
too early to go to sleep so I headed
over to the British Museum of old things
and other miscellaneous Tanja and Jodie
I saw people seeing the rosetta stone
and then after a long while I saw the
rosetta stone itself with its trilingual
declaration that helped us decode
hieroglyphics I saw sarcophagi and tomb
lids and a giant bug and manimals who
guarded the Kings apartment - then we
headed over to the Greeks in the Romans
where I saw this guy with his junk
permanently attached to his toga who was
better off than this guy who was missing
both arms his nose and his junk this
monument featured several decapitated
women and then we saw some more
decapitated women and then yet more
which I guess is where why book
publishers got the idea for the headless
girl cover trend this headless guy is
punching a headless horse who in turn is
kicking him in the balls then I saw an
Easter Island statue and non decapitated
Aztec women and a two-headed turquoise
snake and this thing and this thing
which for some reason I found really
fascinating so I looked on it for a long
time for many different angles and I
still couldn't figure out quite what was
going on so I read the wall label where
I learned that the guy was apparently
about to stab himself in the penis but
more importantly I noticed that the
thing I was looking at was currently on
loan to the Royal Museum of Ontario and
while I was reasonably jet-lagged I was
pretty sure that I was not in Toronto so
in fact think I was not looking at a
thing at all I was looking at an
incredibly well-made photograph of a
thing installed so perfectly that I'm
not sure you can tell that you are
looking at a video of a photograph of a
thing rather than a video of an actual
thing which calls into question the
whole relevance of looking at actual
things when virtual experiences are so
compelling but more on that in a second
I had to keep walking so I met up with
Hank and Katherine and CGP grey who took
us immediately to a crypt you know as
one does that turns out also to be a
cafe where you can dine atop of the dead
we walk through a train station with its
indoor pigeons and then over this bridge
where we learned that you can urinate in
public in England for only 500 pounds
here's a great view of London and here
is do not attempt parkour you will be
impaled by many sticks then we saw a
cafe nerd and a skate park and
Parliament backlit in a down ride
Hogwarts e'en way and an American Viking
on a Harley scooter and the London Eye
which no never know not as long as I
live and then I ran into a nerdfighter
who actually works at the London Eye and
she was lovely and begged me to go but
no never no instead we walked on past a
building heroically rebuilt after its
destruction in her recent James Bond
movie past another cafe nerd and past
Somerset House and we headed to the Tate
Modern and Haig pretended to have
Healy's and we kept walking past the
Globe Theatre and all that remains of
Winchester palace to a pub where Hank
reminded us that even after six years it
is still impossible to act natural when
a camera is pointed at you when we left
it was 4:45 p.m. and therefore very dark
but we kept walking I found my book in a
bookshop and we saw London City Hall and
stopped at last with this view of the
Tower Bridge I found myself wondering
how different it really was from a
photograph I didn't need to be here to
see this after all of course the reason
for our trip was well this but after 30
hours awake in the optical illusion at
the British Museum I couldn't decide if
sites really need seeing or if virtual
experience has become enough and I still
can't decide so I made this virtual
experience for you let me know how real
it feels Hank I'll see you on Friday